despierta no founder and CEO of sistema
de we had the greatest future challenge
to the region the environmental economic
social and out of you I think that she
challenges will be to address your
screen at the same time and this is what
we mean by sustainability today I'm
convincing and only with our life
changing your mindset I relying on
horses energy we need to the relevant
for on sharing know together building of
big companies to outer smaller ones to
winter in sustainability way if we rely
on Liam be companies to change oh well
let's never forget anime represent five
percent of the total as a company we
need now to involve obvious enemies now
just 25 doesn't of a solution